hazmat clad officials not the Welcome
Party they'd hoped for but after being
in coronavirus quarantine for two weeks
on a cruise ship in Japan they're
finally home more than 300 US passengers
flown to safety by their government
ahead another 14 days quarantine before
they're free to go you're exhausted the
first group to be evacuated final health
checks are carried out as they leave 14
more Americans test positive for the
virus on the ship they've left another
99 infections are confirmed the diamond
princess is the single largest
coronavirus cluster outside China while
Australia Hong Kong Italy and South
Korea have announced plans to remove
their citizens British passengers are
still waiting just feel let down they've
made it clear what they intend to do
going to leave it to the hands of Japan
okay thank you
and you know there's more love being
shown to us from Americans and Canadians
than there is from our own country an
email from the British Embassy in Tokyo
shared with Sky News said they're
considering whether to send a plane
we cannot say at this stage whether an
assisted departure will happen it reads
it would help our planning if you could
give an indication of whether you would
be interested in taking a flight back to
the UK please note that this would be
likely to involve a further period of
quarantine in the UK while the Foreign
Office says it's looking at all options
to guarantee the health and safety of
Britons on the ship frustration is
growing I've been in touch with some of
the British passengers onboard and
they're really fed up they say other
countries have been getting their
citizens off yet the UK still tonight
doesn't seem to have a firm plan they
feel forgotten and alone all medical
tests are now complete
so healthy people will begin
disembarking from Wednesday what British
travellers want to know is what happens
next will they believing the ship alone
or with the help of their government
Siobhan Robbins Sky News Japan